today we're here to talk about  artificial intelligence  with three different generations what is  ai  what is a.i what is a.i is a.i evil  it's all actually a matter of our  decision  so what are the main applications of  artificial intelligence  and in which sectors does it develop  from  agriculture to retail from logistics and  transportation to the medical sector and  healthcare  actually ai is and can be everywhere  have you ever seen a robot i don't  remember but i don't think so  well you are using a smartphone here and  now it's a piece of artificial  intelligence  can i trust ai you can trust ai when  it's built according to certain  principles  so we have to address all the issues and  build ai that is trustworthy meaning  that it's controllable  that it's fair and unbiased and that  it's transparent  and then you'll be able to trust it